- Wir wissen nicht, wo Yara ist.
Sie ist nicht hier. Und wir wissen auch
nicht, wann sie wiederkommt.
- Du und Tarek, ihr habt den Schlüssel?
- Ja.
Yara, Tarek und ich sind Freunde.
Sie hat auch die Schlüssel fürs
Restaurant. Wir helfen uns.
- Das ist ja toll!
- Inge!
- Ich möchte noch ein paar Brötchen
kaufen. Kommst du mit, Nico?
- Könnt ihr mir einen Gefallen tun?
Ähm …
wir brauchen noch ein paar Lebensmittel,
aber ich will Tarek im Restaurant
nicht allein lassen.
- Wir können doch für euch einkaufen
gehen, oder Nico?
- Vielen Dank!
Dafür bekommt ihr das
nächste Essen umsonst!
Oh, und könnt ihr mir noch … ähm …
ein Hähnchen, drei Gurken und
ein Pfund Tomaten mitbringen?
- Ein Pfund Tomaten?
Das ist aber nicht viel.
Schreibst du es auf, Nico?
- Das ist für mein Abendbrot.
- Kannst du das bitte noch
einmal wiederholen?
- Ein Hähnchen.
- Hähn-chen!
- Drei Gurken.
- Gur-ken!
- Und ein Pfund Tomaten.
- Ein Pf…?
- Pfund!
- Ja.
- … Tomaten.
- Ein Pfund?
- Pfund. Das sind 500 Gramm,
also ein halbes Kilo.
- Ja.
- Vielen Dank!
Und bis später!
- Tschüss!
- Ah, dann reden wir über
deine Tante, okay?
- Ja.